[MUSIC]
Merges and acquisitions are one of the
most important means by which companies
respond to changing economic and
financial conditions.
It has become one of the favorite exit
strategies for many entrepreneurs and
startups especially
here in Silicon Valley.
The unfortunate reality however is
that the majority of M&A transactions
fail to provide the benefits.
That companies predict or expect to gain.
[MUSIC]
This time for mergers and acquisitions
program is an interdisciplinary overview
of all the major aspects of.
I wanted to attend the program to better
understand how different companies and
different industries go through
the acquisition process from strategy to
integration.
It gives you exposure to a lot
of deals and a lot of thinking.
>> I've had different
levels of MNA experience.
What this program was able to do for
me was have that entire lifecycle,
talk about it.
With people who have had
different experiences and
help my company develop
hard core strategy.
>> One of the keys to a successful
production is understanding
the perspective and the mind set
of the person on the other side.
>> The negotiation class helps solidify
the concepts in a very practical manner.
>> And doing case studies outside of
what you're comfortable with is very,
very powerful.
>> So the program offers participants
an opportunity to get immersed
in a intense yet
very collaborative learning environment.
Our goal is really to provide program
participants with critical insights and
powerful tools.
That will help them more successfully
formulate and execute a mergers and
acquisitions strategy that can really
create value for their organizations.
>> People like me who've done
a lot of acquisitions already.
The, the benefit is just kind ofsharpening
your skills, thinking differently.
>> The program is something now I'm taking
back into my organization, day one.